open world shooters can be the holy
grail of shooters if done right all that
room to roam freedom to tackle
objectives using your wits playing
combined arms with your friends and no
loading screens here's a great list of
open world player vs player co-op and
single player games that you can play
right now hit that like button and let's
get to it oh my god
let's start with player verse player
planetside 2 the idea of massive open
world player vs player battles with
thousands of people has been clawing
around the back of our minds since the
day people dragged their computers over
to each other's houses and hooked them
together for lan parties many have tried
like mag on playstation 3 but few have
succeeded in a way that planetside 2 has
and that's because planetside 2
understands how to spread out objectives
and lock down areas to control player
flow and it's still somehow one of the
only games to have three factions
fighting at the same time there are
fantastic moments in this game like when
two teams are battling over a zone and
suddenly another team shows up and
nobody knows who they're gonna attack or
if they're just gonna sit around and mop
up the winner you can sometimes fight
over a hillside for ages and then have
that like vietnam movie helicopter
extraction moment with your feet
dangling out the side as you lift away
and the war zone just vanishes off into
the distance night fighting in this game
can still just get you to stop and stare
with ordnance crisscrossing the sky
having this unique prism collar effect
more importantly even though there are
up to 2 000 players in a match the maps
are big enough that most of the time
everyone's well spread out and that
means your group can charge in and have
an impact as opposed to some other games
that channel too many players into one
spot and cause you to just kind of get
shot in the back constantly then there
are also those really slow moments where
you won and you get to breathe and
collect your forces then roll out in
these massive convoys planetside 2 isn't
perfect it even flirted with loot boxes
at one point which the community pretty
roundly rejected but it stood the test
of time literally our award from 2012 is
still on the download page it's a game
that's growing and recently expanded
with even more maps one a water world
the learning curve isn't too bad with
the addition of an instant action button
and a fairly large unlock tray to keep
you busy plus you can take on a number
of high earning support rolls it'll be a
while before you're ready to pilot
aircraft but learning is the fun part oh
and it's free
armor reforger is an early access
testbed for arma 4. a game still in
development but we're going to go with
for forger on this list because if
you're going to play arma 3 you've had
about a decade already to do that
reforger's map is massive about 51
square kilometers and has two modes
conflict and game master in conflict
teams fight over points on the map with
or against each other game master lets
you craft custom scenarios and even have
someone essentially dungeon master the
game around you you want to play this
game with organized groups who know what
they're doing it's a sim through and
through so expect a lot of slower paced
moments where you sit there and plan
then travel to an objective and then get
those intense firefights arma has always
conveyed a great sense of danger through
sound design and when you start hearing
bullets whiz and snap around you with no
idea where they're coming from it's
genuinely terrifying that's a sound that
puts the fear of god in you real fast
being an arma game set in the 80s don't
expect a lot of high-tech gadgets and
indicators like waypoints you'll need to
dust off your map and compass skills
talk about distracted driving for longer
running fans of the series you'll notice
some quality of life improvements thanks
to the new infusion engine like a better
frame rate a much better looking world
especially when it comes to water
decorated building interiors foliage
rendering at greater distances character
animations in and around vehicles and
while performing actions the ability to
climb objects base building a cleaner
inventory system with saved loadouts and
modular vests oh and it's on xbox or
steam on pc
world war ii online was apparently one
of the first mmo first person shooter
games and is for players that have a
heavy desire for nostalgia and who are
looking for a slower paced world war ii
milsim style game this game has been
around in some form or another since
2001 it had a steam early access release
in 2017 and holds a few guinness world
records including largest playable area
in a shooter video game graphically it
looks pretty old but developers are
working on an unreal engine 4 version
called world war 2 online chokepoint
that could bring visuals more in line
with modern titles this game is fun to
check out if you're curious and has some
features that were well ahead of their
time objectives are captured in similar
ways to battlefield's conquest mode with
teams holding down flags they're high
level commanders issuing orders and
things like mobile spawn points to get
you closer to battles soldiers can build
on the map setting up sandbags and
emplacements in more freeform ways than
battlefield v unlike faster paced
shooters world war ii online isn't
afraid to use more period appropriate
bolt bolt-action weapons and lots of
troops don't have semi-auto rifles the
game doesn't have a kill camera so to
avoid long hikes and quick deaths you
want to link up with an organized group
honestly after spending some time with
this game i probably barely scratched
the surface it's somewhat of a curiosity
and if you have time to explore systems
could be very satisfying
star citizen is a game for people
willing to spend money on a game that is
forever in development it's always been
a bit buggy with a pretty steep learning
curve this game will also ask for a lot
of money like
45.75 starter packs ships priced up to
several hundred dollars that require a
crew to operate and larger game packages
costing over a thousand dollars you'll
need to buy a ship to do anything
including first person combat star
citizen does have an enthusiastic
dedicated fan base of people who love it
and are probably willing to teach you
the game has added first person combat
in some pretty interesting ways lately
it allows you to go bounty hunt other
players after they commit crimes which
means breaking local space laws like
missile locking authority bumping into
stations or taking on criminal missions
you can also play as an emt space medic
which sounds really cool for support
focused players in that role you go out
and rescue people you get into trouble
and call for help the medical system is
honestly pretty robust on top of that
players have engaged in some large 50v
50 battles it looks pretty epic star
citizen seems to be delivering on a
massive and expanding universe with
large cities ships that not only have
fully built out interiors but ship
hangers to fit smaller ships in and now
plenty of ground combat with places to
raid if you fancy the ability to not
only engage in dogfights but then also
get out and storm the interiors of ships
this game could be for you time to
switch gears and talk about co-op far
cry 6 is a whole lot of far cry it is
all of the other far cries it's a
culmination of tons of different systems
from across the series including more
controversial rpg mechanics that took
root around far cry new dawn but far cry
has always been and still is an
immensely satisfying romp through a
massive world full of dangerous animals
hilarious glitches and memorable bad
guys like voss and pagan men so if
you're a bigger fan of far cry 3 4 or 5
we're still here for you we're just
going to focus on 6 for this particular
section like the past few far cry games
in 6 you can play co-op with a friend
although keep in mind far cry uses a
tether system that won't allow players
to stray too far from one another that
can complicate things if one person is
attacking from the air and another on
the ground or one of your buddies just
wingsuits off leaving you behind the
game is also cross-generational play not
cross-play which means you'll have to be
on an xbox if your friends on an xbox or
a playstation of your friends on a
playstation you can just be on an
earlier version of the console there's a
ton to find in this game's large open
world including plenty of secrets more
importantly the map is set up so that
side activities alerts you less
aggressively than they have in past
games and you don't constantly feel the
need to go do them and risk getting
burned out before completing the main
campaign an advantage of the game's role
playing mechanics is that it can be very
difficult if you stray into the wrong
zones under leveled which becomes more
of a fun challenge when you have a
friend alongside you enemy helicopters
in particular are hard to take down a
disadvantage of the rpg system is that
guns are kind of all over the place with
some flashy ones being ineffective and
some bland ones being super powerful so
you'll need to experiment there's
extensive gun modding in this game which
is a lot of fun to mess with guns and
far cry have always had this unique
scrappy loose feeling to them that kind
of sets them apart but yeah seeing your
friend get attacked by a wild animal
just never gets old but to be honest the
face eating eagles from far cry 4 were
kind of the pinnacle there
bad bird
ghost recon wildlands is probably one of
the purest ubisoft games i've ever
played and you can enjoy it with three
other friends one of the biggest
challenges with ubisoft games as i've
just mentioned in far cry has always
been getting distracted and burned out
by side missions while chasing the main
plot and let's be honest trying to
absorb the plot while your friends are
eating doritos into the comms is already
a challenge but wildlands is pretty much
all side missions meaning there's really
no pressure to pay attention to the
dialogue when all you want to do is
screw around anyway the game is
completely open from the start and you
can go to any region although some are
tougher than others the biomes are
genuinely gorgeous where you drive
across shallow lakes with flocks of
flamingos crew salt flats and battle
through heavily forested jungle ub has
an absolutely a tier world design team
the game also sports some very fun
combat systems like sync shot and
upgradable drones you can do things you
wouldn't expect too like shoot out tires
pop bad guys through building windows or
pull off some well-timed combined arms
warfare you can even zero the scope of
your first sniper rifle for accurate
long-range shots if you prefer you can
jump into the more recent title break
point which has gone through a lot of
changes since its troubled launch they
added immersive mode that stripped out
the loot system either game lets you
just enjoy yourself with friends state
of decay 2 is an excellent end of the
world game and oddly enough the
juggernaut edition was the last title i
saw in person before the pandemic
started one of the most requested
features from the first state of decay
was the ability to survive the zombie
apocalypse with other players and that
dream in this nightmare world came true
you can pull in up to three people
although the players that join have some
limited functionality like they can't
bring resources back to their own games
you will absolutely need all the help
you can get because state of decay 2 is
a thinking person's game you need to
listen to that little voice in the back
of your head when it tells you that
you're out too late pushing your luck
scavenging when you're low on health and
then you wind up crashing in a ditch
next to a zombie horde with a long jog
back to your base that's important
because your players can die permanently
if you're new to the series you will
need to wrap your head around the idea
that you aren't one person but instead
jumping between controlling several
different people at each of your bases
state of decay 2 might be a bit slower
paced survival and resource game but has
great weapon systems with players
needing to keep track of different guns
and ammo types with the juggernaut
edition it's on steam and cross play on
xbox one xbox series xns and pc
it's time for single player fans out
there when it comes to open world
shooter set in the apocalypse it's hard
to beat metro exodus the sheer
brokenness of this world is so pervasive
in all your gear in the locations and
how everything is taped together recycle
they're just falling apart it's a game
that scratches that post-apocalypse
scavenging and survivage without you
having to punch trees or deal with other
players being jerks like in a million
other pv pve survival titles the systems
in the game are a lot of fun and you can
use your backpack to craft and mod
weapons mid-battle kind of like how it
worked in the last of us multiplayer
weapons feel very homebrew and need to
be cleaned and maintained another really
great aspect of this game is that the
people you meet in the world feel very
believable they seem to want to survive
like when you wind up having a shootout
at an enemy base they'll realize they're
not going to win and start surrendering
and hopes you won't kill them
combat is also more grounded and you'll
encounter creatures that you can't kill
right away and occasionally a random
enemy bullet will just kill you
instantly now even though metro exit has
made this open world list it has more
large areas than a massive open world
and it can get linear at times entering
side missions from the open world is not
totally seamless and there's a lot of
these press x to squeeze through small
space moments it just kind of pulls you
out of the world all in all this game
gives you the best of everything great
characters a story for more linear games
and tons of open space to roam and build
your arsenal if you fancy yourself a
real survivor you can even try ranger
hardcore difficulty that removes your
heads up display reduces resources and
gets rid of manual saves you prepper you
[Applause]
is cyberpunk 2077 still buggy
yeah the bugs are more funny than
frustrating these days like how my new
motorcycle has that guard cat meme
energy
but if you were put off by the
brokenness before you probably missed a
lot of great side missions the economy
revamps also mean plenty of stuff in the
game is now affordable like cars in
newer apartments with a better economy
and ability to reset your stats you can
experiment with a wider variety of
combat styles or even combine them but
more importantly to truly understand and
enjoy this game you have to stop
thinking of night city as an open world
in the ubisoft sense and think of it
more as a character and a hub for
activities all the best stuff to do is
marked on the map and if you wander
around just looking for random
encounters like you wouldn't a fallout
game you'll be disappointed but if you
just rush between those markers or worse
fast travel between objectives you'll
also really miss out on the character
that is night city i've taken to role
playing this game now first person only
when driving walking in crowds rather
than sprinting like a weirdo and
stopping to listen to conversations on
the street about how someone didn't want
their child to join a gang or a young
girl asking why her mommy had to go to
heaven instead of arasaka because they
didn't have the money to put her there
and then we could go and see her
together every day i like to end each
day with my character in bed and just
looking at my apartment window and
admiring the dust storms that roll
through i truly believe this is the best
way to play cyberpunk to experience how
much love and detail went into the
environmental storytelling the lighting
and general graphics also just look
amazing on pc romances have been
expanded so you can go have a wholesome
cuddle with pan am or maybe get some
saucy texts this is your chance to go
find adam smasher's secret hideout climb
up to the secret mansion and find out
it's locked now for some reason and
generally just exist in the world stop
and smell the chrome roses take a selfie
with bibi from death stranding ride a
roller coaster with johnny and as the
community put it best for those at end
game meet hanukko at embers nah i don't
think i will
red dead redemption 2 made this list
thanks to a really well made first
person mode the online component may be
dead with the community basically
holding a funeral recently but if you
haven't tried the main story in first
person it winds up being a slow-moving
immersive sim with moments of existence
punctuated by exciting gunfights red
dead 2 is set in an absolutely gorgeous
world particularly on pc and full of
incredible details and stories from
1899. those details are not lost on
weapon models which you can see while
aiming down sights going first person
also lets you get away from rockstar's
usual tiny aiming dot i mean you still
have to turn it off in a menu but it was
always just there designed for a third
person lock-on system you can admire
weapons by inspecting and cleaning them
as well as modify them in shops
first-person melee combat is pretty
brutal in ways you'd miss in third
person on top of guns you also have a
host of gadgets the best being the lasso
which you can use in both gunfights and
when throwing hands it just does not get
old roping somebody in the middle of a
gunfight for people who gravitate
towards more modern weapons there are
few semi-auto pistols later in the game
it's important to remember that red dead
2 does have a classic gta style police
system so if you're on team do crime
you'll become wanted and the law will
chase you through the entire game
finally keep in mind you'll need to
tweak some settings for the best
experience so go in there and change how
the lock on system works set controls to
standard fps and mess with head bobbing
to keep the screen from shaking too much
after that getting to first person view
as a button press and toggling your
weapon to aim down sights is another
button press the game will then remember
everything and you're good to go what
game should be on our next best open
world shooters list our office had
pretty mixed feelings about halo
infinite so tell us why or why not we
should include it on the next one thanks
for watching
oh